the AIRAID sirens wailed across Riyadh
today it was just a test of the system
planned before last weekend's attacks
but given the tensions right now it is a
sound that focuses minds after a night
in Saudi Arabia and talks with the crown
prince the US Secretary of State left
for the United Arab Emirates in Abu
Dhabi Mike Pompeo met with Crown Prince
Mohammed bin Zayed and it seems it was a
productive trip I was sent here to work
to make sure that I understood how our
friends and allies here in the region
were viewing the challenge in the
threats posed by the Islamic Republic of
Iran I certainly accomplished that and I
think I'll be able to give the president
some important information about how it
is we should think about proceeding but
as he heads back to Washington it is
still not clear what action will be
taken the problem of course with blaming
the Iranians so explicitly is that the
two sides are compelling themselves to
respond and yet neither the Americans
nor the Saudis have any desire to go to
war with Iran Iran continues to deny any
involvement in the weekend attacks
despite all this wreckage of Iranian
weapons which the Saudis say proves
their culpability Iran doesn't want a
military escalation either but the
foreign minister said today all-out war
will be the consequence of any u.s.
strike on its country with no
negotiations at all between the
Americans and the Iranians once again
it is via social media that the two
sides clash old habits die hard Foreign
Minister Zarif tweeted to mr. Pompeo he
included an old video in which the
former CIA director brags about lying
and cheating West Point he will not lie
cheat or steal or tolerate those who do
I was the CIA director we lied we
cheated we steel stole it's like we had
with the entire entire training courses
any company that they wanted me across
the region now though there is genuine
consensus that these latest attacks do
demonstrate more aggression by Iran that
must be countered it's always been
listed the way I mean even with the
Houthis even with Iraq even with
yuria we always go back to Iran and we
say this is the militia Hezbollah is a
militia by uranium in Lebanon we had in
Syria there's also militias in Iraq
there's almost 44 militias and the
Houthis so we always pointed to Iran as
he headed back to brief the president in
Washington Mike Pompeo stressed again
that this trip was a mission to find a
way out of this but if there's another
attack what then